did you realize that most of the damage
from drinking alcohol doesn't actually
come from drinking alcohol let me
explain
now when you drink alcohol your liver
has to break it down and it does it
through an enzyme called alcohol
dehydrogenase so the byproduct of what
this enzyme breaks alcohol into is
called acetaldehyde here's the problem
this by-product is highly toxic even in
low concentrations it has ability to
increase collagen growth in the liver
that's called fibrosis as in cirrhosis
of the liver
so this by-product causes oxidation and
free radicals it's the free radicals
from the byproduct that cause
destruction of the liver so then you
have a sequence of things that happen
you develop a fatty liver then you get
inflammation and the inflammation is
there because the body is trying to heal
something what is it trying to heal the
damage to the liver
okay then scar tissue develops and you
get cirrhosis now there are various
studies done on rats they fed rats
alcohol with a high-fat diet and they
found that this process actually
accelerates so just realize and this is
what they don't tell you that high-fat
diet was really combination of high fats
and high sugars okay it wasn't just a
high-fat diet so they omitted that one
little point and the problem is when you
add sugar to high fat or sugar to
protein you really spike the insulin
levels so you can pretty much just omit
and cross off this study because this
does not relate to what we're talking
about now here's the problem the liver
doesn't give symptoms until there's
extensive damage so you can go on for
years and years and years without any
symptoms and notice your gut increasing
but you might not make the connection
but that's what's happening the liver is
filling with fat it's spilling off
around the organs and it's ending up as
a visceral fat so there's a lot of
extensive damage taking place but
without a lot of symptoms initially so
in the liver you have these little
functional units that detoxify they do
many things
they're called lobules so you
anywhere between 5,000 and 10,000 of
these units and they're nourished by
blood and they do a lot of things from
digestion to cleaning toxins but what
happens is when you get inflammation and
scar tissue you're going to start losing
the function and a lot of things going
to happen from a loss of energy
production and this is why you might get
tired but the liver is robust and it has
the ability to regenerate but there is a
point of no return where there's so much
damage you can't reverse it and of
course the liver has the ability to
regenerate of course if you stop doing
things that are causing a destruction so
antioxidants have the power to protect
these functional units of the liver now
your body makes antioxidants and you get
any oxidants from your foods and when
you run out of these antioxidants your
cells become more susceptible to the
damage now the problem is you can't just
go to GNC or the drug store and buy a
bottle of antioxidants to protect your
liver why because those are made
synthetically and the way the
antioxidants work are in networks you
have many different types of
antioxidants because when the
antioxidant donates an electron to the
free radical to stabilize that atom that
antioxidant now is unstable and it needs
an electron from another handy oxidant
so that's why you need a network and
this is why you always want to get your
antioxidants from foods or food
concentrates so here's a picture of a
free radical let's say we have two
electrons that are supposed to be there
and you're missing one electron so it's
an unpaired electron so a free radical
is an unpaired electron these electrons
are spinning around this atom and ones
missing so if you imagine a disc that
just has one weight on the side and it's
spinning and it's just going all over
the place because it's not symmetrical
that would be kind of a simple concept
to understand this so an antioxidant
gives up one of its electrons to
stabilize this free radical but then it
becomes to that degree of free radical
so this could stabilize but now this one
needs another electron from another
Antioch
so this is why many different in
accidents are necessary to pull off this
job this also explains why some drinkers
get cirrhosis and some don't
it really has to do with that
individual's antioxidant reserves
usually people that drink don't eat
healthily also if you drink in smoke you
accelerate this process even more
because the free radicals from smoking
but if you compound this and you smoke
and drink and eat junk food you're
really gonna be in trouble
alright guys so what can you do to solve
this other than give up the drinking
okay if you're gonna drink it's very
very important to consume a diet that's
extremely high in antioxidants okay so
make sure you're consuming a lot of
leafy greens and the more someone drinks
let's say they're an alcoholic the
greater amount of vegetables they should
be consuming the healthier the diet
alright guys thanks for watching I'll
see in the next video
so if you want more knowledge on how to
create a healthy body subscribe now and
get daily notifications daily
notifications that sounds weird well
I'll just remind you on a daily basis
how about that